[Music]
okay so this is my review
of your honor episode six so it opens up
with michael connecting the dots
that this blackmailer that was in the
green camry
is the green camry that's on the footage
behind adam at the gas station but he
can only make out a little bit of the
license plate so he uses his magic
on nancy costello and gets her to give
her information on similar license plate
numbers to figure out where this
car and person is you see already how
much
michael has transformed he says a line
to
nancy here in the diner look at me
asking you to bend the law even though
i'm the one who asked people to uphold
the law
calling himself a hypocrite and she's
like you're the furthest thing from a
hypocrite
but we know as the audience how that is
so not true and he is one of the biggest
hypocrites
you can follow as your main protagonist
a lot of the opens of these episodes
have been with michael trying to do
something next in his plan
whether it's hide something or find
something out what i liked here didn't
drag
its feet too slow here in the diner and
quickly gave us now
jimmy baxter in the home of michael he's
literally marking his territory here
even leaving a little pee driplet
on the toilet seat turning photos around
and what was interesting is he finds an
inhaler
in the bathroom and it reminds me again
of them getting the dna tested on the
inhaler i really wish they wrote in a
line kind of
updating us on did the baxter family
ever get an update on that
it kind of disappeared after they said
it would come back in three days i think
it's the strangest thing that that's
kind of been forgotten about
at this point but the stakes are already
rising early in this episode seeing
jimmy baxter now
this aggressive in the home so michael
on his journey to find the man who's
blackmailing him
he runs into this old man ed
in a nursing home and what really worked
well for me in the scene was they used
this character of ed
not only to lead to his son trevor who
michael's actually looking for but to be
a character we can take a step
back in michael's brain catch up with
him and what he's thinking and feeling
and he confides in him talking about how
much pressure he's feeling
saying i got a man trying to ruin my
life and secrets i can never tell
anyone but what really stood out to me
in the writing here was when
ed says to michael about how precious
the gift of a child is
and michael says back that type of love
can just crack you
open make you something you never
thought you could be this is such a
strong line because it really is just
subconsciously implanting the theme of
the show into our brains here about
how far love will take you and
especially this type of love where it's
your son or your child in general
and what is right and wrong and
connecting to michael what would you do
in this situation i think that's where
the show shines the most and it's
important that
they keep kind of giving us some scenes
like this to connect
with michael here and have some empathy
so
with adam and fia here they take a big
part of this
episode and i was laughing so hard
there's always moments that adam i have
to laugh but one in particular moment i
think takes the cake now over his crazy
dancing scene i think it was in episode
three
is when v is telling him she's wearing
rocco's old
shirt and asked him to smell it that was
one of the most awkward scenes i can
remember on television and strange
and he sniffs it i just started laughing
but it gave me pure enjoyment watching
that because it was so funny
and you just wonder like how frustrating
adam is as a person
and what is his plan here what is he now
going to date
the sister the guy he killed and just
think oh i'll get to that part that i'm
holding that big secret right killed her
brother later on how is he going to hold
that in and then
michael over here is breaking his back
and he's just going on
fun little dates but really i want to
give props to
the actress here of fia lily kaye who
does an incredible job this episode we
really got to see her acting chops here
because
this was her most lines in an episode
and i thought her
and adam actually had amazing chemistry
which was really cool to see
and this was actually good casting by
the show with fia because the actress
looks like the daughter of michael
stoolbarg so that was definitely a home
run casting choice and especially
because she acts so well and it add to
more things that frustrate you about
adam
he decides you know what let me take a
photo of fia while she's sitting in this
cart in this abandoned amusement park
he's literally just like
giving everything that could work
against him to the universe
but what i thought was important here
was that fia is telling adam that people
misread her
father and that he came from nothing and
that he is actually a good man i think
this will be important to our central
storyline because i think this is gonna
obviously give adam the wrong idea about
jimmy baxter where his father has been
warning him that jimmy baxter is a
madman which is true and will kill him
but now adam's gonna be
kind of sympathizing and thinking the
way fia is thinking and i think they're
setting that
up that he's just gonna stupidly trust
jimmy baxter now i love at this point in
the episode
we get stories colliding when we see
jimmy baxter and his henchman frankie
are sitting in the parking lot of
michael's house while
adam and fear are pulling up from their
date and michael is actually inside of
the house
again adam's just a complete psychopath
kissing her here
like dude come on you killed her brother
i again just everything with adam makes
me
just giggle a little bit but what's
interesting is that when they see adam
go
into the house to michael their plan
originally was to kill michael here
and then it throws it off that adam
comes out but it really throws it off
because jimmy sees adam came out of his
daughter's car
so frankie's like you want me to kill
both of them and jimmy's like
no points to leave so it actually
protected and saved michael's life that
adam went on this date which is just so
ironic
i like that they had jimmy discover that
fia
and adam are a little item right now
because it's gonna
complicate jimmy baxter's character so
he's not just full on revenge mode
trying to kill both of them that
yeah he'll try to kill michael but
something's gonna now be in his way of
just getting rid of adam
and that's gonna be him thinking of his
daughter what really makes me excited is
the line between fia
and jimmy baxter where they're talking
about adam and she's like why don't you
just get them over here you can talk to
them in your office yourself i would
love to see this scene with a character
like jimmy face to face with adam really
just
smack some sense into this kid also a
little thing i caught was that
when michael is talking to adam in the
home here they're having a nice moment
talking about
adam's mother his wife that passed away
when he finishes a story about how they
met michael's like
and then the next 30 years began and
adam goes 32
and corrects him that's super important
i think it leads to my theory that
something was
up before the mother died in those last
two years that i don't know
if like i said maybe michael was having
an affair with lee
or something just was off with their
relationship and clearly something
we're gonna learn about what exactly
went down with the mother is gonna be
the big
x factor in this whole story i believe
now there's also this development of
carlow
who is trying to prove worthy to his
father by
basically taking over the town and all
these different groups through
these drug deals so what was interesting
about that is that
gene of the mom seems already suspicious
of her son and he's now this
thing that's the part that's like the
atom of the baxter side where he screws
things up for them
and his bad choice making and now which
will get to the end a big reveal about
him
i also have this feeling if i'm gonna go
big long game theory of this show
it hit me when adam was with fia and
they're looking at nyu and he's about to
do his big interview
he's uncertain about going into it now
but the way
it's just presented with them together
in the timing of it when he's about to
have this big interview
and how they just had the scene where
michael was like no i want you to go i
feel like
it's gonna end this show where adam and
fear are the ones who
go away and they go to new york start a
new life and that their fathers are the
one who
pay the piper in the end here for all
their sins that's my theory where this
is going especially because they've
introduced this
love story but time will tell but my
favorite thing about this episode was in
the end because
when lee figures it out that kofi
was killed by carlo baxter and then gets
even dna of carlo baxter on kofi's body
this is the perfect plot
twist to add in in the timing of it
because it's the way we can justify
michael actually surviving being in a
room with jimmy baxter and a gun
this is an awesome final scene in the
warehouse jimmy's about to just shoot
him
and we see michael make that play that
he's like i can make sure carlos
case is in my court make sure he walks
out of free man i'm gonna say it because
i do it every review
and again here's another reminder of
walter white in my head because i just
think of how he got out of gus
killing him by using an upper hand on
someone
like gail it just felt so similar again
it's not an
issue but again i have to acknowledge it
most people have watched breaking bad
these memories are gonna flash back in
moments with brian cranston but it's
such a great
exciting thing they're setting up for
the end of the season because it's just
now really making this just all crazy
and
now he's gonna try to make carlo baxter
free man to save his own life it's gonna
be a wild finish
and i love the moment when jimmy points
the gun towards trevor lying on the
floor there and he's like what does this
man know and michael says
everything because he knows too that it
actually helps him if jimmy shoots
trevor there and gets rid of one problem
for him so overall i'm giving this
episode a
nine i thought it was one of the
stronger episodes of the season
i felt like every scene had weight and
purpose and that
it still gave you payoffs here
by episode six thank god because it's a
ten episode season what i mean by that
is being
able to already see jimmy with michael
now going head to head and that jimmy
mostly knows what the audience knows
about what michael's doing
and i like this adam and fia story
because it's adding a
huge variable to this war between
families and how they both can be ones
that
change the whole script of what's going
to actually go down in this show
like i said lee finding that out i
thought was great they brilliantly leave
that in
about kofi and carlo the timing of it to
have something michael can use
so we can realistically believe he'd get
out of that warehouse alive
let me know down below what you thought
of this episode i'd love to hear your
thoughts i read every comment try to
respond as many as i can
if you like what i do here i ask if you
could please donate
two dollars a month you can subscribe to
this donation in the paypal link down
below it will help me do more videos for
you guys and make my dream reality of
doing this full time and please make
sure to obviously subscribe to the
channel so you don't miss any of my
reviews of your honor i'm also reviewing
the show serving at the moment i'll be
doing movies and celebrity interviews
and please follow me at steve varley
show on twitter and instagram for more
of me
and i'll see you next time